Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I just finished reading this paper and I fell
out of the chair.
And I can almost guarantee you that the results
in this work are so insane, you will have
to double, or even triple check to believe
what you're going to see here.
This one is about image translation, which
means that the input is an image, and the
output is a different version of this input
image that is changed according to our guidelines.
Imagine that we have a Monet painting, and
we'd like to create a photograph of this beautiful
view.
There we go.
What if we'd like to change this winter landscape
to an image created during the summer?
There we go.
If we are one of those people on the internet
forums who just love to compare apples to
oranges, this is now also a possibility.
And have a look at this - imagine that we
like the background of this image, but instead
of the zebras, we would like to have a couple
of horses.
No problem.
Coming right up!
This algorithm synthesizes them from scratch.
The first important thing we should know about
this technique, is that it uses generative
adversarial networks.
This means that we have two neural networks
battling each other in an arms race.
The generator network tries to create more
and more realistic images, and these are passed
to the discriminator network which tries to
learn the difference between real photographs
and fake, forged images.
During this process, the two neural networks
learn and improve together until they become
experts at their own craft.
However, this piece of work introduces two
novel additions to this process.
One, in earlier works, the training samples
were typically paired.
This means that the photograph of a shoe would
be paired to a drawing that depicts it.
This additional information helps the training
process a great deal and the algorithm would
be able to map drawings to photographs.
However, a key difference here is that without
such pairings, we don't need these labels,
we can use significantly more training samples
in our datasets which also helps the learning
process.
If this is executed well, the technique is
able to pair anything to anything else, which
results in a remarkably powerful algorithm.
Key difference number two - a cycle consistency
loss function is introduced to the optimization
problem.
This means that if we convert a summer image
to a winter image, and then back to a summer
image, we should get the very same input image
back.
If our learning system obeys to this principle,
the output quality of the translation is going
to be significantly better.
This cycle consistency loss is introduced
as a regularization term.
Our seasoned Fellow Scholars already know
what it means, but in case you don't, I've
put a link to our explanation in the video
description.
The paper contains a ton more results, and
fortunately, the source code for this project
is also available.
Multiple implementations, in fact!
Just as a side note, which is jaw dropping,
by the way - there is some rudimentary support
for video.
Amazing piece of work.
Bravo!
Now you can also see that the rate of progress
in machine learning research is completely
out of this world!
No doubt that it is the best time to be a
research scientist it's ever been.
If you've liked this episode, make sure to
subscribe to the series and have a look at
our Patreon page, where you can pick up cool
perks, like watching every single one of these
episodes in early access.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!